aus welchen grund hat donald trump ein
derart starkes interesse daran die
islamische republik iran und zu
bestrafen
[Musik]
falls ihr die vorangegangen videos zu
dieser fähre gesehen habt könnt ihr mir
glauben dass sie darum geht die ölpreise
in die höhe zu treiben
seinen saudischen freunden zu helfen
oder einfach der europäischen union zu
zeigen wäre jeder post
[Applaus]
aber hier kommt eine weitere these was
ist wenn das hauptziel trumps das ende
der autoritären herrschaft im iran ist
aber handelt es sich nicht um eine
weitere kleine dumme theorie
der iran steht am rande des
wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruchs proteste
gegen die regierung sind an der
tagesordnung und im gegensatz zu anderen
ländern der region verfügt der iran über
eine weltliche liberale und
demokratische opposition
das bedeutet dass man keinen echten
krieg führen muss um in diesem land die
demokratie wiederherzustellen
es könnte ausreichen das regime in den
finanziellen ruin zu treiben
dass dieser plan so gut läuft wie es
klingt wäre dann als traum ein kandidat
für den friedensnobelpreis
obama würde verdammt alt aussehen und
schon würde die wahlen 2020 gewinnen
aber was ist wenn es nicht so gut läuft
wie geplant ist dass alle dollar
anschieben wirklich so schwach wie alle
denken kann trump diese wette überhaupt
gewinnen das alles werden wir in diesem
video ausführlich besprechen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
amerika liebt es den herren zu hassen
natürlich behauptet das weiße haus mit
den atom sanktionen nicht das regime
stürzen zu wollen aber ist dass die
ganze wahrheit
[Musik]
us sicherheitsberater john bolton sagt
dass die vereinten staaten nicht
versuchen irans regierung zu stürzen
sondern nur wollen dass die regierung in
teheran ihr verhalten ändert
fakt ist dass amerika seit jahrzehnten
versucht die macht er hat nur das
einzudämmen hast du zum beispiel mal was
von radio free europe gehört während des
kalten kriegs schuf der amerikanische
kongress diesen rundfunksender um die
bevölkerung der ostblockstaaten mit ein
wenig opa ghana gegen die kommunisten zu
begrüßen und auch nach dem fall der
sowjetherrschaft existiert diese anstalt
noch in ihre büros liegen ganz in der
nähe von wo aus sich dieses video
aufnahme in prag und jetzt ratet mal
womit sich diese rundfunkanstalt heute
befasst dieses radio hat eine ganze
abteilung nur für den iran
die produzierte nachrichten in farsi der
sprache der perser und botschaften gegen
das eine tolle regime in iran zu
verbreiten
das ist doch schon ein recht starkes
indiz dass washington durchaus einem
regimewechsel in teheran interessiert
eine andere frage ist ob dies überhaupt
möglich ist oder nicht
und jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht ist
der iran wirklich eine so schlimme
diktatur letztendlich halten sie dort
wahlen ab nun ja und nein es ist wahr
dass die iraner ihren präsidenten wählen
können aber die person mit der
eigentlichen macht im staate ist der
oberste führer ajatollah kommen
bestimmt die meisten minister und hat
das letzte wort was internationale
angelegenheiten und viele wichtige
gesetze an
[Musik]
und natürlich werden die kritiker und
dissidenten von der regierung
unbarmherzig verfolgt und oft sogar
ermordet tatsächlich gibt es einige
oppositionsbewegungen aber diese
verfügen über so gut ich keine starken
führungspersönlichkeiten warum nun alle
die sie mal hatten sind heute tot
eingesperrt oder im exil und wie sieht
es mit den politischen kräften aus die
das derzeitige system unterstützen nun
statt mutiger parteien sollten wir hier
über verschiedene fraktionen sprechen
auf der einen seite haben wir hardliner
die das von khomeini geschaffen das
system unterstützen einen totalitären
gottesstaat und staatlich gelenkte
planwirtschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf der anderen befinden sich reformer
die das regime von innen heraus
verändern wollen die macht dieser
fraktion ist heutzutage nur noch sehr
klein
schließlich gibt es noch die pragmatiker
deren wichtigster vertreter der
derzeitige präsident ist hasani sie
verorten sich irgendwo zwischen
hardlinern und reformern und zeigen sich
offen für ein paar wirtschaftsreformen
und etwa bessere beziehungen zum westen
wollen aber dennoch eine gewisse
religiöse kontrolle in politischen
angelegenheiten behalten und hier haben
wir die zweite frage ist es wirklich
möglich dass dieses ganze politische
system auseinander fällt nun es gibt
keine chance zumal wenn die wirtschaft
gut läuft ist es auch einfach ein
autoritäres system am laufen zu halten
den menschen tauschen wohlstand
bereitwillig gegen freiheit aber der
iran hat die wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen belange seiner bevölkerung
lange vernachlässigt die iranische
währungen der realwert tag für tag ab
und was wird zu einer brutalen inflation
laut inoffiziellen schätzungen betrug
sie im letzten jahr mehr als 100 prozent
das bedeutet tägliche preissteigerungen
viele lebensmittel wie fisch geflügel
werden immer knapper
und es gibt immer mehr menschen die
unterhalb der armutsgrenze nehmen selbst
die privatisierung der regierung helfen
der wirtschaft nicht aus dem chaos das
jahr 2018 begann mit massiven protesten
gegen die regierung hani viele dieser
demonstranten waren junge
universitätsstudenten die ein system
wechseln wollten ein wechsel zu einem
demokratischen weltlichen und liberalen
system
[Musik]
im jahr 2009 10 fiel das mullah-regime
dann durch die blutige niederschlagung
von protesten auf bei der es über 1000
demonstranten getötet
außerdem ging der iran zum gegenangriff
auf die us streitkräfte im irak über
diese angriff ging jedoch gehörig schief
prompt ließ den chef der
revolutionsgarden tsunami anfang des
jahres 2020 durch einen drohnenangriff
töten und beim anschließenden
vergeltungsschlag blamierte sich das
iranische regime durch den abschluss
eines ukrainischen zivil flugzeugs kurz
nachdem dieses vom teheraner flughafen
abgehoben war somit gegen diese als
pr-aktion geplante racheakt gegen die
amerikaner gehörig schief die iraner
schafften es genau null amerikanische
soldaten zu töten dafür aber 176
unschuldige zivilisten die meisten davon
in kanada lebende iraner auf ihrem flug
aus dem heimaturlaub und dann kam auch
noch wie die strafe gottes oder
vielleicht des spaghettimonsters das
corona virus bei dessen bekämpfung der
iranische staat einen äußerst schlechte
figur abgibt
[Musik]
es gibt also war nicht gute gründe dafür
dass es in der iranischen bevölkerung
immer mehr brodelt
aber die eigentliche frage hier ist
reicht das alles aus um einen
regimewechsel herbeizuführen
heute werden wir diese frage beantworten
aber bevor wir das tun blicken wir wie
immer kurz zurück in die geschichte
die bread oriana gerade im iran 1979
begann die islamische revolution in iran
der damalige oberste führer ajatollah
khomeini wusste dass die armee in jedem
moment verraten könnte
[Musik]
nachdem sie jahrzehntelang dem star
gedient hatten ziel den militärs ein
realitäts wechsel über nacht äußerst
schwer
um einen staatsstreich zu verhindern
ökumene seine eigene parallel armee auf
diese weise entstanden die islamische
revolutionsgarde eine art moderner
koreaner gerade zum schutze des
islamischen regimes
[Musik]
am anfang war sie ein sammelsurium von
freiwilligen aus allen möglichen
paramilitärischen vorgänger
organisationen die in ihr
zusammengefasst wurden aber die dinge
änderten sich schnell in den 1980 er
jahren damals begann der krieg zwischen
dem iran und irak ein sehr brutaler
krieg und bin schickte man an die front
natürlich die revolutionsgarde welche
bereit waren alles für ihre sache zu
gehen
in kriegszeiten sitzt das geld für mehr
waffen und eine ausrüstung sehr loch auf
diese weise gewann die islamische
revolutionsgarde immer mehr einfluss
mehr waffen und mehr erfahrung
am ende des iran irak krieges hatte die
gäste bereits mehr als 130.000 soldaten
sowie viele andere kleine kurs die von
ihnen abhängig machen
[Musik]
heute haben sie ihren eigenen
geheimdienst parallel zum geheim nächste
regierung und sie können gegen menschen
ermittlungen durchführen und sie sogar
verhaften ohne sich dafür bei
irgendeiner anderen behörde oder bei
einem gericht verantworten zu müssen mit
anderen worten sie sind die eckpfeiler
der islamischen revolution aber
andererseits sind sie ein staat im
staate doch damit nicht genug was die
wirtschaft betrifft fällt es extrem
schwer eine alternative zum system zu
schaffen wenn es eine elite einheit gibt
es jeden ausspionieren kann und eigene
wirtschaftliche interessen
und ja wir sprechen hier von einer
elitetruppe perfekt ausgebildet eine
hybride kriegsführung
[Musik]
sie haben in vielen anderen kriegen
syrien irak und sogar afghanistan
gekämpft und alle experten sagen ihre
ausbildung seien absolute weltklasse
kommen wir aber nochmal zu den
wirtschaftlichen aspekten der
revolutionsgarde zurück du fragst dich
vielleicht wie kommt es dass sie an so
viele waffen
ich meine wenn iran wirtschaftlich total
so wie jetzt wo kaufen sie diese ein nun
die wahrheit ist dass der iran seit
jahrzehnten seine eigene waffe industrie
ist und ja erst richtig gehört
der iran nutzt chinesische und russische
x1 aber die herstellung übernimmt er
selbst wie wirken sich die
wirtschaftssanktionen auf die
revolutionsgarde aussetzen die diese
nicht unter druck nun liebe zuschauer
weit gefehlt
[Musik]
extra druck und der mangel an
ausländischen konkurrenten werden der
iranischen revolutionsgarde
höchstwahrscheinlich helfen deren
einfluss auf die iranische wirtschaft
weiter zu verstärken ali al honi
arabischen golfstaaten institute in
washington
wie bitte ja tatsächlich liegt ein
großer teil der iranischen wirtschaft
direkt in den händen der
revolutionsgarde
sie ist im besitz vieler staatlicher
unternehmen darunter ölgesellschaften
raffinerien und immobiliengesellschaften
zum beispiel gehören ihr 51 prozent der
iran telekom
wenn man jetzt auch noch bedenkt dass
sie so gut wie vollkommen von der steuer
befreit sind haben wir hier wirklich den
perfekten staat im staate inklusive
einer eigenen volkswirtschaft gegen eine
derart starke und gut versorgte parallel
armee lässt sich am regime wechsel
neusser schwer durch zu
und deswegen war die liquidierung von
custom solle man dem top general der
revolutionsgarden und unbestritten
zweitmächtigste mann im iran für die usa
so wichtig
[Musik]
sam soliman usa töten hochrangigen
iranischen general bei luftschlag in
bagdad wenn du jetzt aber dachte es
diese mächtige revolutionsgarde wäre die
einzige trumpfkarte der alto lastern
erst du dich gewaltig denn passiert ist
gut aus
jeder kommt zur hilfe in dieser serie
von videos haben wir mehrfach betonen
dass ich hier nach weiterhin öl aus dem
iran kaufen wird sie können nicht
einfach so damit aufhören denn china
braucht viel erdöl sehr viel erde und
seit jahren ist er ihre an der sechst
wichtigste rtl in proteine
wir sprechen hier von über 800.000
barrel die tat aus dem iran kommen
[Musik]
bei solch gewaltigen zahlen ist es recht
schwierig plötzlich den anbieter zu
wechseln
und ja ich weiß was du jetzt denkst wenn
ihr die vorherigen videos gesehen habt
wisst ihr bereits das in amerika eine
geheimwaffe hat um länder davon
abzuhalten iranisches öl zu kaufen
grundsätzlich kann keine öltank schiff
in einen hafen anlegen wenn es nicht
versichert ist und die meisten
versicherungsgesellschaften sind
europäische oder amerikanische
unternehmen also wie könnte ich hier
weiterhin öl aus nehmen ihre ankaufen
und tanker zu sich transportieren
schau dir das mal
exklusiv china steigt auf iranisches
tanker um damit das öl trotz sanktionen
weiter fließen kann
ja das ist so richtig gehört auch ohne
die versicherungsfirmen übernimmt der
iran den transport das ganze risiko und
auch alles andere müssen die öltanker
gewartet werden der er an zahlt ein
schiff was wegen der meere
kein problem der iran sei aber das ist
nicht das ende der veranstaltung
überlegt mal wenn der rest der welt
seine investitionstätigkeit generale
einstellt wer bleibt übrig freie fahrt
für geld aus china
[Musik]
ein chinesisches unternehmen investiert
2 milliarden dollar in öl raffinerie im
iran auch das so richtig verstanden
china springt in jene bresche die andere
unternehmen hinterlassen haben
tatsächlich kommen sie ganze investments
europäische unternehmen so begann
beispielsweise der französische
ölkonzern total im jahr 2016 mit dem bau
einer förderanlage auf dem größten
gasfeld der welt im iran aufgrund des
aktionszeitraums sieht es nun so aus
dass total dieses projekt total
einstellen muss und er ist bereit ist zu
kaufen
[Musik]
im sommer 2008 zehn kündigte die china
development bank an dass sie mehr als 15
milliarden dollar an krediten für
mögliche projekte im jahren vergeben
wird ihr müsst mich vielleicht fragen
ist das viel oder eher wenig geld nun es
hat dem iran bereits geholfen fünf
brandneue krankenhäuser zu bauen und was
ist mit anderen unternehmen erinnert
euch daran als ich auch davon erzählt
habe dass der iran einer der größten
automobilhersteller der region ist nun
eine der haupt märkten ist super
sie haben bereits ein joint venture mit
einem anderen chinesischen unternehmen
namens brilliance unterzeichnet und das
ist erst der anfang
mal sehen kennst du das ehrgeizigste
projektiert es handelt sich um die von
bertram roth die neue seidenstraße die
dinge bauen möchte und jetzt stellt euch
vor wo einer der wichtigsten
knotenpunkte liegen
[Musik]
china sieht iran als wichtigen
knotenpunkt der seidenstraße bislang
wurde bereits mehrere eisenbahn
die idee besteht darin die wichtigsten
iranische städte mit hochgeschwindigkeit
zu verbinden auf denen dann waren wir
vielleicht warum mir das dann so richtig
schau dir einfach diese karte also um
jurist ist da stehen
[Musik]
stellt euch ein güterzug voller
mobiltelefone vor der aus china kommt
durch zentralasien fährt und dann vom
iran in die türkei sieht durch den
perfekten weg für china aus und seine
produkte in europa zu schicken nicht
wahr
natürlich ist das bisher nur eine idee
chinesische unternehmen stehen in
zentralasien bereits vor vielen anderen
problemen aber das ist eine frage für
ein ganz anderes
fakt ist dass hier damit beginnt stark
im iran zu investieren bedeutet dies das
ziel bringen die iranische wirtschaft
retten wird natürlich nicht aber wird es
am ende reichen dem iranischen regime
das überleben zu sichern
nun vielleicht schon und das erklärt
warum sich die politischen beziehungen
zwischen diesen beiden ländern in den
letzten jahren immer weiter verbessert
haben
[Musik]
think pink führt gespräche mit
iranischen präsidenten hassan el hani
jetzt bist du an der reihe glaubst du
wirklich dass die sanktionen von trump
das zeug dazu haben dass ayatollah
regime zu stürzen
lasst euch mit euren theorien ruhig im
kommentarbereich unten aus falls ihr
tiefer in die details der atom
sanktionen eintauchen wollt könnt ihr
euch die ganze serie an sehen wir
veröffentlicht haben
und vergesst nicht wir so alt politik zu
abonnieren und auch das blocken symbol
zu pflegen damit ihr ja kein unserer
wertvollen beiträge verpasst falls ihr
dieses video gefallen hat geht uns einen
leichten und die immer sehen wir uns das
nächste mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]